[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
i have to for this sentence ensure that
the only time mr halderson comes back
into the community
is to
have the privilege of a burial that he
denied his parents a judge hands down
the sentence to chandler holderson
following his conviction for killing and
dismembering his parents plus i was
asked to
analyze the records and and
see how many times
billy turner talked to sarah we found
186 calls between july 5th 2010 and
august 5th 2000
cell phone records tell more of the
story of how nba player lorenzen wright
lost his life and she knew the
activities of jamarcus glover i don't
think she was physically moving any
narcotics i've never thought that i
think she was being used by these guys
and placed her in positions that
obviously had a very negative outcome an
officer involved in the brianna taylor
raid is speaking out john manley gives a
first-hand account of what happened the
night of the no knock war but first i'm
not suicidal okay i am not
suicide i am innocent and i am not
suicidal a surprising turn after jesse
smallette serves just days of his
sentence in chicago law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin some shocking news out of chicago
jesse smallade is out of the cook county
jail after being granted a release on
bond pending the appeal of his
conviction this comes after less than a
week into his sentence for a hate crime
hoax that cost the city thousands of
dollars smaller was convicted in
december of five felony counts of
disorderly conduct for lying to police
he claimed he was the victim of a racist
homophobic attack a jury agreed with
what the prosecution alleged that the
actor recruited two brothers to fake the
attack for publicity a cook county judge
sentenced somalia to 150 days in jail
last week just as the sentence was being
handed down but before being escorted
from the courtroom smolette stood up
from the defense table yelling i'm not
suicidal and after just six nights
behind bars and a motion from his
attorneys an appellate court sprung the
former empire actor from jail wednesday
night the decision reportedly based on
the facts mullet likely would have
already served his jail time before his
appeal would get very far it was also
noted the actor had never been convicted
of a violent crime smellout's attorneys
have argued he shouldn't have even gone
to trial after last year's promise from
the prosecutors to dismiss the case in
the initial indictment based on a deal
the case was reinvestigated months later
which brought renewed charges
joining us today is former chicago area
detective and swat member lisa lockwood
and terry austin lisa you predicted the
jail time from the get-go and now he's
out pending an appeal what was your
reaction when you first heard the
decision
i did not predict six days for jesse to
be released
the wheels of justice can be slow
sometimes but in this case with an
incredible high paid dream team that he
has on staff um it went very swiftly for
him my social media was blowing up my
telephone what happened what happened
how in the world did he get out and i
think you alluded to it earlier brian
when you made the comment that he wasn't
a threat he was never arrested and there
was no concern that he was going to jump
bond so i think that's what we're
dealing with here today now terry the
appellate judge laid out their reasons
for releasing somali do you agree
disagree how did you feel about those
i do not agree it was a one-page order
it was less than one page actually they
listed two reasons they said first of
all that it was non-violent i agree with
that reason but the second reason they
gave i don't agree with they said that
to release someone because the appeal
could take longer than the actual
sentence is not a good reason first of
all it shouldn't take 150 days to decide
that's five months but second of all
every defendant can make that argument
if they are waiting for an appeal even
one day in prison is too long if they
actually win that appeal so
regardless of the length of that
sentence i think frankly judge lynn had
every right to set an example and i
think he was trying to do that it was a
serious crime hate crimes are very
serious and to make it up i think was
something he should be punished for all
right so now the appellate court has
this case of course give you updates as
that begins will the sentence stick will
will the verdict stick you gotta keep
watching law and crime daily for all of
your updates still ahead on law and
crime daily a cell phone expert takes
the stand in the case of slain nba
player lorenzen wright but first a sit
down with former louisville police
officer sergeant john madden what he
says happened the night of the infamous
briana taylor raid
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury bonus
[Music]
welcome back one of the forward police
officers involved in the raid on briana
taylor's apartment is speaking out with
a new book about that night and policing
in general law and crimes angen levy is
here with what john manley has to say
antoinette
brian john mattingly was shot the night
of that raid and he ended up
retiring from the louisville metro
police department after this incident we
spoke about briana taylor what happened
that night in the recent acquittal of
his former colleague brett hankerson
brett as far as that night i tell you
what he did what any i think logical
friend would do in that situation he
thought we were getting executed at the
doorway and
he was willing to risk his freedom risk
his life to stay in the fight with us
and move around
and do what he could to get us out of
that doorway now retired louisville
metro police department sergeant john
mattingly on a jury finding brett
henkerson not guilty of wanton
endangerment charges related to the raid
on briana taylor's apartment hankerson
had been charged with endangering
taylor's neighbors by firing his gun
into taylor's apartment mattingly says
he thinks back to that night about what
could have been done differently i had a
lot of guilt you know going into this
you feel like man if i had done
something different at the door maybe
these guys wouldn't be in the situation
they're in mattingly has written 12
seconds in the dark a police officer's
first-hand account of the briana taylor
raid he blames briana taylor's boyfriend
kenneth walker for her death mattingly
says they had authorization for a
no-knock warrant that night but ended up
knocking six times and announcing
themselves before entering taylor's
apartment walker fired at the officers
wounding mattingly and mattingly miles
cosgrove and brett hankerson fired back
i don't really know the truth
i know for sure he admitted he heard us
knocking
he said he didn't hear us announced
mattingly believes had officers used the
no knock warrant that night it might
have actually saved taylor's life since
there wouldn't have been time for walker
to react and arm himself police were
executing the warrant looking for
evidence of drug trafficking against
taylor's ex-boyfriend jamarcus glover
number one it's a tragedy i have i've
mourned her loss i feel bad for her
family
i've prayed for her family but at the
same time the situations we put
ourselves in whether it be police
whether it be civilian whether it be
whoever it is
she knew the activities of jamarcus
glover she knew i don't think she was
physically moving any narcotics i've
never thought that i think she was being
used by these guys jamarcus glover had
his vehicle registered to briana's
apartment he had his bank account there
his phone bill came to her apartment and
just back in january she had bailed him
out on another gun and drug charge
and they used her address saying it was
his so all the all the roads led back to
brianna's apartment taylor's death led
to widespread protests and unrest and
calls for police reform
now i contacted kenneth walker's
attorney for a comment on john
mattingly's claims and his new book and
he says that this book
will further divide the community and is
causing more distress for kenneth walker
walker's lawyer goes on to say that it's
a lie that walker knew that the police
were entering the apartment and that he
had a right to stand his ground brian
thanks aunt jeanette let's bring back
former swat member and detective lisa
lockwood and terry austin as we discuss
manly speaking out with his book terry
what's your reaction to matlin's
interview and how do you think brianna
taylor's family feels about this book
first of all great interview angenet and
i basically understand how all three of
those officers shot back they were in
fear of their lies they were shooting in
response to being fired upon but i don't
think that it's fair to blame kenneth
walker he was actually doing the same
thing he was defending himself and his
girlfriend brianna he too was in fear of
his life and like the officers he was
defending himself so i think it's a
tragic situation i think the family's in
pain and there's no need to throw more
salt into those wounds yeah lisa do you
think it's safe or even wise for manly
to write a book and speaking publicly
when there's still a doj investigation
on this case
yes i think everything is very raw right
now even still a pending investigation
his safety was threatened he and his
family were forced to move uh three
hours away from louisville uh during
this time period so just for the safety
aspect alone and then the legal aspect i
think striking while the iron is hot is
probably what he wanted to do while the
case is relevant
however i don't think it was the best
decision for himself for his safety and
also for the members of uh family
members of briana taylor yeah and
jeanette what is the louisville metro pd
and the city of louisville saying about
the book and matli's claims
well of course i reached out to both
lmpd and the city of louisville mayor
fisher's
representatives and you know the city
settled with brianna taylor's family i
think everybody realizes this was a
tragedy and uh briana taylor should not
have lost her life
that night a spokesperson for the
louisville metro police department told
me that lmpd is aware of the book and at
this time lmpd respectively declines
comment and then a spokesperson for
mayor fischer told me that mayor fisher
has not read the book and that is all
she had to say yeah i mean my two sense
is read the book make up your own mind
see what's in there as to what you agree
or disagree with but just as a defensive
attorney um kind of with lisa is saying
i would hesitate to say my client should
be writing a book about what's going on
when there's an investigation but to
each their own and of course like terry
was saying the family of brianna taylor
this has to be adding salt to the wound
i can't imagine this is something that's
kind moral i don't know how you want to
put it there but we'll see how this
continues as the book and more attention
to this case continues thank you all
coming up on law and crime daily a
sentence is handed down for the
wisconsin man convicted of murdering and
dismembering his parents plus the murder
of nba star lorenzen wright we head to
tennessee as his accused murderer stands
trial
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
cell phone expert testifies that
lorenzen wright's ex-wife an accused
killer sends a string of coded text
messages before and after his death the
one-time nba star was reported missing
in july 2010 when he didn't return calls
to family members his body was later
found in the tennessee woods near his
mother's home seven years after his
death the murder weapon was recovered in
a mississippi lake that's when defendant
billy ray turner was arrested and later
charged with wright's murder prosecutors
say wright's ex-wife shara wright
recruited turner to shoot and kill her
ex-husband they say she was after the
basketball player's life insurance
policy sharon wright was later charged
in connection to her ex-husband's murder
she's currently serving a 30-year
sentence for facilitating the murder on
wednesday cell phone expert sergeant
dennis evans took the stand telling
jurors that the same cell phone service
area that picked up wright's final 911
call also pinged turner's cell phone
just two minutes later he also detailed
the messages sharer wright deleted after
they were sent and received
so what we're looking at here on the
left is the actual message what we can
see
we can tell it came from the phone it
was on july 18th at 11 47 in 17 seconds
we can tell that it was a sent sms
message
and we can tell that it was a message
sent to billy turner at his phone number
if you look at the top left the top
arrow there's a red x
the red x indicates that it was deleted
and that our software was able to
recover it
so this is
essentially
28 minutes before the 9-1-1 call but
these are the messages between shara and
billy that night
mr turner then responds
at 11 49 and 04 seconds
we can tell the date time is is 7 18
2010 at 11 49 or two minutes after that
she sent the text
and then you've got it was to
mr turner or i'm sorry from mr turner so
this came from him to her
and then the the body of the text was
okay
detective lisa lockwood and co-host
terry austin join us as we decode the
murder trial of lorenzo wright lisa
these
not-so-coded messages seem to point the
murder uh on to the murder are these
messages and cell phone pinging tying
turner to the murder enough for a guilty
verdict
that in itself is not enough but we do
know the weapon did belong to him they
weren't able to extract fingerprints
from it because of the degradation of
being in the water for such a long
period of time but all of these other
items are circumstantial it doesn't put
him immediately in the vicinity of him
where you know that those two phones
were together within a certain amount of
feet but the conversations and also the
pinging does put them in that area it is
helpful but on its own merits it doesn't
it doesn't stand up to um the fact of
giving him a conviction we still need
more information yeah i know in law
school we would call it like the bundle
of sticks one stick can break on its own
but you add multiple sticks together it
makes for a stronger argument that can't
be broken makes a lot of sense when you
put it all together there thanks lisa
terry the defense attorney tried to
discredit the testimony of the cell
phone records expert do you do you think
they made any points
no i don't think they made any points
sergeant evans was pretty strong on that
stand he's an expert in digital
forensics and he was certified in
extracting and analyzing phone data and
one of the things the defense tried to
do is to say that he only had training
for one week and it was in 2016 and it
wasn't in 2010 but hey guess what he
extracted and analyzed that data just
recently so it doesn't matter if he was
certified back in 2010. he also tried to
say that he had never testified on
behalf of defendants but that too
doesn't matter because he was an
employee
of the authorities of the police so of
course he's not going to be testifying
for defendants so i think all in all it
uh didn't make any headway there yeah
they're trying to poke some holes in the
credibility it doesn't seem like they
did it enough at least for you uh terry
will continue to follow this case giving
you gavel to gavel coverage of course
here the law and crime network when we
come back a sentence is handed down for
the man convicted of murdering and
dismembering his parents but just how
long will chandler holders spend behind
bars we head to wisconsin for the latest
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily just
months after he is found guilty on all
accounts convicted killer chandler
holderson is sentenced to life in prison
without the possibility of parole long
crime daily brought you gavital gavel
coverage of the trial out of wisconsin
where halderson murdered his parents
bart and krista holderson in july 2020
after that he dismembered their bodies
burned pieces of the remains in the
family fireplace and scattered the rest
of the remains across the southern part
of the state at the time halderson
reported his parents missing to
authorities and even appeared on local
television stations asking the public to
help find his parents he claimed they
visited a family cabin in the northern
part of wisconsin over the fourth of
july weekend but never returned after
only a few hours of deliberation the
jury found halderson guilty on all
counts back in january on thursday
prosecutors urged judge john highland to
hand down the maximum penalty
part of the risk of chandler is he
doesn't look like a dangerous guy
he's packaged up into like a normal
middle-class kid
and
was able to
fool everyone not only fool everyone
about these crazy lies about work and
school and activities
but fool everyone into believing
that he was a safe person to be around
that he was trustworthy that he wasn't
going to
not exaggerating the fact shoot you in
the back
because that's in fact what happened
someone in mr halderson's shoes with his
mindset can never be safely in this
community
his willingness to solve
the minor inconveniences of life with
brutal
violence
can never be mitigated in our community
as long as he breathes he will be a risk
i've never heard of a crime more serious
i've never heard of a crime more brutal
mr halderson's mere presence in our
community the fact that he did any of
this
has ripped apart the fabric
of of our community
the idea that someone can live amongst
us with no warning signs and commit such
heinous acts
should scare everybody and it sure as
hell scared everybody here
no one who's interacted with mr
halderson will ever be the same
after both the prosecution and defense
attorneys addressed the court halters
himself briefly spoke out
your honor i want to take this
opportunity to state my intent to appeal
my convictions
if there are any lawyers listening and
willing to take on my appeal
take a moment to please reach out to me
it's not that i do not have feelings
is that i was warned to not show them
due to the scrutiny of this case
thank you
lisa what do you think of holders and
requests initially not to be president
of the sentencing and then the judge's
subsequent denial of that
i i saw that as him being a coward not
only is he a vicious monster who
committed these crimes against his
beautiful loving parents but the fact
that there's been zero remorse nothing
and even in the end with his final
statement uh stating that he wasn't
told not to show emotion is him still
not taking accountability and playing
the blame game
so
no parole
opportunities to me obviously life he's
going to have but no parole means that
the general public will be protected
here on out for as long as he's alive
and i'm grateful for that decision yeah
i know in many cases we've heard the i'm
not going to give emotion i'm not going
to give an impact statement kind of
thing with pawn sentencing
but this where it's your parents i think
there's a little wiggle room for that i
think a lot of defense attorneys will
agree terry thursday was one of the
first times you heard hollison address
the court what'd you make of his call
for a new team of attorneys
listen brian his statement was as
cold-blooded as he is he's saying he's
intending to appeal as if his own
attorneys did not do a good job but if
anyone is listening please reach out i'm
not sure he's going to get a response to
that because there are no viable grounds
for appeal then he went on to say as you
heard that it's not that he doesn't have
feelings he was warned not to show it i
am certain that his attorneys did not
tell him don't show any feelings at all
they probably said don't react when you
hear testimony because you want your
client to look cool and calm but not
cold and calculated so i happen to agree
with the prosecution and with the judge
this crime is even more heinous because
his parents as we just heard were the
most loving parents you could have
possibly had
all right so that's kind of but maybe
that's the end of the chapter for
channel halloween season of appeal but
we'll keep you updates as that
progresses thank you for joining us here
law and crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you